No I want you to remember all the way
back to the start of year two fm1 we've
done anything wanted it to do you men
want if it was here's my name we'll all
of the echoes on my manager the specific
one was earning and managing money okay
now one of the things you remember I
hope is that we looked at this idea of
net income net income does anyone
remember what net means in this context
okay so it does mean after some stuffs
been taken out okay we would usually
talk about that it's gross
take away the deductions very good now
in FM one in FN one the reason why we
thought about that one and cause if you
want to manage your money your purse
income is not a useful number to you
because you're like yeah I've got my
gross income but a lot of that money I
can't access because it gets used up by
this and this and that the other okay so
if I click net income that's the real
figure that's gonna be important to you
because that's what I can like use to
travel or to save up for something or
buy a car or whatever it is
okay so that was the context of an
income but right now we're gonna take
the same idea just look at it in the
context of tax we give these slightly
different names okay so we would say the
taxable income which for intents and
purposes is basically parallel it's an
area code it's not your gross income but
your I know it's very very good so it's
your total income and we're still going
to subtract deductions
now this subtraction junctions were
really familiar with that all the
different costs that get removed from
your tax your total income things like
if you're giving to charity if you've
got salary sacrifice those kinds of
things but totally calm Christa's our
mind up isn't just necessarily from a
job right where else could you get money
from apart from just the job
okay youth allowance good something else
so that's yes and he's any kind of
Centrelink social payment yeah yeah very
good sir if I owned a property apart
from the one I'm living in right I'll be
renting that out which means I will be
getting income from that does that make
sense and I'm gonna have to pay tax on
that is there anywhere else I could get
income from apart from my job and my
justice to those don't come it's like a
regular and you'll be okay okay so we'll
talk about tax returns in a second I
will get to that but for reasons they'll
become clear that actually doesn't
comment to total income I will say one
last one that's important and that's
bank interest
now most us don't think about that
because I don't like when I had a bank
account like this is back in the days
when you got your yeah I hadn't told my
account and you get your this is pretty
mail right so you get all of your
account statements in the mail and I'd
get one the end of the month and I'm
like wow I have made seven cents of
interest this month
yes so we don't think about very much
but fairly quickly you guys will have an
amount of income where it is relevant so
that's
okay just so we're ready to proceed taxa
wake up this man is too much okay when
you work out your taxable income as you
can imagine well that leads to how much
tax you have to pay right your income
tax now it's very important that you get
that taxed right because it's sort of
inconvenient Majan if you're getting
your total income all the way throughout
the year and then you get to the end of
the year and you're like older I had
this huge amount of tax that I owe the
government and I've been kind of
spending all my money and I don't I
can't pay the government back right that
would be a big problem especially like
someone like me I pay like I don't know
it's thirty to forty thousand dollars in
tax every single year I'm kind of
screwed if I end up every single year
year-on-year racking up that amount of
debt right so the government and all the
employers are kind of forced by the
government to fix this by doing
something instead of tax caps and
obvious change today
we introduced this the all the
government uses the scene called PAYG
taxes anyone don't want co-writer sexual
okay good so what does that mean though
okay good so in other words the
government's like hahaha I don't trust
you to save up 30 to 40 thousand dollars
all the way throughout the year I'm just
gonna take it off you as we go every
time you get paid I'm just not gonna pay
you the whole amount but here's the
thing the government doesn't know what
your deductions are gonna be because
everyone's is different does this make
sense
so PAYG tags is kind of like it's not
kind of like it is you should write this
it's an estimate of total income tax
okay it's an estimate of total income
tax